2 Menschen, die auf der Titanic
zueinander finden.
I'm flying.
Von denen wird nur eine Person
den Untergang überleben.
Die Liebesgeschichte
von Jack und Rose ist so tragisch,
dass Fans nach Wegen suchen,
wie Jack hätte überleben können.
Und weil "Science vs. Fiction"
beim Namen Jack rührselig wird,
gönnen wir ihm ein Happy End.
Wir haben uns
eine Historikerin geschnappt
und checken 3 Optionen
für sein Überleben.
*Filmmusik: "Titanic"*
Tag zusammen!
Jack Pop hier.
Vor 25 Jahren
kam die Liebesgeschichte
von Jack und Rose in die Kinos.
Was dabei
aber nicht untergehen sollte:
Die Katastrophenfahrt der Titanic
ist nicht nur ein Film.
Die Tragik und Dramatik
hat tatsächlich stattgefunden.
Jack Dawson gab es so zwar nicht.
Trotzdem gibt es Parallelen
zu echten Personen,
mit teils krassen
Überlebensgeschichten.
Ob es Jack doch hätte schaffen
können, checken wir jetzt.
Gemeinsam mit der Historikerin
Janine Funke.
Janine ist Redakteurin
des Podcasts "Terra X History",
aber auch wissenschaftlich unterwegs.
Sie forscht
zu Militär- und Computergeschichte.
Auch zum Wasser hat sie einen Bezug.
Sie wohnt in Spanien
und dort direkt am Atlantik.
Schön, dass du da bist.
- Ich freue mich auch.
Wenn wir zurückschauen:
Kannst du dich noch erinnern,
was du gedacht oder gefühlt hast,
als Jack das 1. Mal
damals von uns gegangen ist?
Ich kann mich gut erinnern.
Ich war ziemlich jung,
8 Jahre alt,
als ich die VHS-Kassette
das 1. Mal zu Hause geguckt habe.
Ich war ziemlich traurig.
Ich habe den Film oft geguckt
und musste jedes Mal weinen.
Heute kann ich das Ganze
aus der Historikerin-Brille schauen.
Da ist es nüchterner für mich,
den Film zu gucken.
Aber trotzdem emotional.
Das hat einen mitgenommen.
Wir wollen deine
Historikerinnen-Sicht haben.
Lass uns das Ganze
von hinten aufrollen
und mit dieser ikonischen Szene,
wo er entschwindet, starten.
Weil es so lange her ist, brauchen
wir einen filmischen Rückblick.
Den gibt uns freundlicherweise
Lisa von Giga TV Mag.
In dieser Szene sehen wir
die letzten gemeinsamen Minuten
der beiden.
Jack hilft Rose
auf die schwimmende Wandverkleidung.
und spricht ihr Mut zu.
You're gonna die an old ...
... an old lady, warm in her bed.
Not here.
Er möchte eines von ihr hören:
Dass sie überleben wird.
I promise.
Als ein Rettungsboot umkehrt,
sind nicht nur die Schreie
der anderen Passagiere verstummt,
sondern auch Jack.
Für ihn kommt die Hilfe zu spät.
Rose löst ihr Versprechen ein.
Sie wird vom Rettungsboot
aus dem Wasser gezogen und überlebt.
Danke, Lisa.
Janine, wenn wir uns diese Situation
historisch anschauen:
Ist die Szene korrekt dargestellt?
- Ja, ziemlich.
Wenn wir uns anschauen,
wie viele Menschen
am Ende überlebt haben,
die im Wasser waren,
das war nur eine Handvoll.
Da sind tatsächlich
ziemlich viele gestorben.
Liegt es daran, dass das Rettungsboot
so spät umgekehrt ist?
So ist es im Film dargestellt.
We waited too long.
Wie ist die Rettung abgelaufen?
Schauen wir uns historisches
Material und Zeitzeugenaussagen an,
können wir sagen, Passagiere
wurden vom Rettungsboot 14
in andere Boote umgestapelt.
Das hat Zeit gekostet.
Aus mehreren Gründen
hat es eine ganze Weile gedauert.
Man musste sich
durch die Trümmerteile
und die Leichen kämpfen.
Man hat nichts gesehen.
Es war eine sternenklare,
mondlose Nacht.
Also extrem dunkel,
keine Lichtquellen.
Man hatte auch keine Scheinwerfer
wie im Film.
Man hatte nur Öllampen.
Die machen keinen großen Lichtkegel.
D.h., da jemanden zu finden,
ist gar nicht so einfach.
Wahrscheinlich kann man diese Zeiten
nicht so genau einschätzen?
Da hatte ja keiner eine Stoppuhr.
Nein, wir können das nachrechnen
und ungefähr schätzen.
Aber wir können nicht
in die Zeit zurückreisen.
Wir wissen nicht,
wie lange das gedauert hat.
Das hat keiner
akribisch aufgeschrieben.
Es ist eine Schätzung.
Im Film ist es so dargestellt,
dass Rose die Glückliche ist,
die auf dieses Rettungsboot
kommen kann.
Und zwar, weil sie sich
auf ein Stück Treibgut gerettet hat.
Das war ein Knackpunkt
der Fan-Diskussion,
ob Jack nicht mit draufgepasst hätte.
Wir haben das schon besprochen
in einem Short, dass ich verlinke.
James Cameron hat das Experiment
vor Kurzem nachgestellt.
Er hat eine Position gefunden,
in der die beiden
zusammen auf die Wandverkleidung
gepasst hätten.
So hätten beide den Oberkörper
aus dem Wasser gehabt.
Wenn Jack mit darauf gewesen wäre,
wäre das besser für ihn gewesen?
Zu dem Zeitpunkt wäre es
seine einzige Chance gewesen,
zu überleben.
Aus dem historischen Material
wissen wir, dass das Rettungsboot 14
nur Menschen von Trümmerteilen
gerettet hat.
Es gibt ein historisches Beispiel.
Den chinesischen Passagier
Fang Lang,
der ähnlich wie Rose sich auf eine
Tür oder Tischplatte gerettet hat.
Er wurde dann in das Boot gezogen.
Er war aber schon steif vor Kälte.
Man dachte schon, er ist tot.
Er hat aber überlebt.
Er war einer von 2 Leuten,
die am Ende aus dem Wasser
von den Trümmerteilen
gezogen wurden.
Und danach auch noch überlebt haben
in dem Rettungsboot.
Man muss sich vorstellen,
die Leute waren im Wasser,
total unterkühlt.
Noch die Nacht zu überleben,
war die nächste Herausforderung.
Er hat extremes Glück gehabt?
- Auf jeden Fall.
Ich sehe noch ein anderes Problem,
wenn Jack das auch so gemacht hätte.
Also mit Rose auf die Tür setzen.
Fang Lang hat man liegend gefunden.
Er war mit einem Seil
an dem Treibgut befestigt.
So musste er sich nicht festhalten.
Das macht Sinn.
Es war extrem anstrengend.
Jack war vorher im Wasser.
Er hätte viel Kraft
aufwenden müssen,
um mit Rose
auf dieser Tür zu sitzen.
Ich bezweifle, dass er,
historisch und biologisch gesehen,
noch die Kraft gehabt hätte,
nachdem er im Wasser war,
sich noch geprügelt hat und so.
Stimmt, das schwankt alles
und du musst dich koordinieren.
Dann haben wir eine Stellschraube,
an der wir drehen können.
Um das zu überleben
und Rose nicht zu gefährden,
muss Jack also Ruhe bewahren
und Energie sparen.
Es gibt eine historische Person,
die genau so überlebt hat.
Und zwar sogar ohne Treibgut.
Wo diese Person im Film auftaucht,
zeigt euch jetzt Lisa.
In dieser Szene befinden wir uns
kurz vor dem Untergang.
Das Schiff neigt sich schon langsam
und alle flüchten
Richtung Schiffsheck.
Auch Jack und Rose.
Als sich das Schiff aufstellt,
klettern sie auf die Reling
und warten auf den Untergang.
Neben ihnen kauert ein Typ in Weiß
gekleidet, mit einem Flachmann,
aus dem er sich einen großen Schluck
genehmigt hat.
Er verlässt mit Jack und Rose
als Letzter das Schiff.
Diese Figur fällt einem
nicht nur im Film ins Auge.
Sondern auch, wenn man
nach Überlebenden googelt.
Da taucht er hier auf.
Charles Joughin,
der Chefbäcker der Titanic.
Er war Vorlage für diese Filmfigur.
Er hat angeblich 2 Stunden
im Eiswasser überlebt
bei knapp unter 0°C.
Noch ein paar Beispiele,
warum er genau die Ruhe weghatte,
die Jack dringend gebraucht hätte.
Er war als Kapitän in einem
der Rettungsboot vorgesehen,
hat aber den Posten nicht angetreten.
Von Bord hat er eine Reihe
von Stühlen ins Wasser geschmissen,
damit die Leute
sich darauf retten können.
Im Wasser hat er es
zu einem Faltboot geschafft.
Er entschied sich dagegen,
mit auf dieses Faltboot zu klettern,
um die Leute darauf
nicht zu gefährden.
Was ich spannend, aber auch
passend zur Szene finde, ist:
Er soll so entspannt gewesen sein,
weil er besoffen war.
Das wäre schön,
wenn es so gewesen wäre.
Ist das der Grund für sein Überleben?
Das wurde auch bei der Befragung
im Britischen Untersuchungsausschuss
thematisiert.
Diese These hält sich hartnäckig und
wurde in älteren Filmen dargestellt.
Charles hat in seiner Zeugenaussage
angegeben,
ein halbes Glas Whiskey
getrunken zu haben.
Ob er deswegen
wirklich überlebt hat,
halte ich für historischen Blödsinn
aus 2 Gründen:
Zum einen wird sich der Alkohol,
der in seinem Blut war
und diese beruhigende Wirkung hatte,
nicht ewig gehalten haben.
Der 2. Grund, rein medizinisch:
Der Alkohol musste abgebaut werden.
Das kostet Energie.
Am Ende ein Null-Summen-Spiel.
Ein halbes Glas Whiskey
klingt nicht nach zu viel.
Ich habe von 2 Flaschen gelesen,
also viel mehr.
Ist der Rest auch überzogen?
Da ist auch viel Mythos dabei.
Charles wird ein bisschen
als Held dargestellt.
Das passiert oft in der Geschichte,
dass eine Person rausgenommen wird
und der Held ist.
Das sehen wir auch bei der Titanic.
Viele Sachen, die wir gesehen haben,
stimmen nicht unbedingt,
historisch gesehen.
Z.B. dass er seinen Platz
bzw. seinen Posten im Boot
verweigert hat.
Wahrscheinlich wartete er
auf eine Anweisung des Offiziers,
die nicht kam.
Die Sache mit den Stühlen,
die er ins Wasser geworfen hat,
stimmt wahrscheinlich auch.
Aber es war Eigennutzen dabei.
Denn er wusste,
er muss selbst ins Wasser.
Dann die Frage mit dem Faltboot.
Es heißt,
er ist nicht draufgeklettert,
um die anderen zu schützen.
Wahrscheinlicher ist aber,
dass er runtergestoßen wurde
und deswegen keinen Platz
auf dem Boot bekam.
Oh wow, miese Nummer.
Aber es ist ein Kampf
um Leben und Tod.
Da kann man sich das vorstellen.
Das klingt weniger heldenhaft,
als es woanders beschrieben wird.
Jetzt hat er am Ende
trotzdem überlebt.
Wie hat er das gemacht,
wenn er nicht so abgeklärt
oder betrunken gewesen ist?
Es könnte daran gelegen haben,
dass er im Wasser
keine wilden Bewegungen gemacht hat.
Er sagte aus, dass er nur ein
bisschen hin und her gepaddelt ist
und seine Füße und Beine bewegt hat.
Das ist eine schlaue Strategie.
Das würde man heute
in der Seenotrettung
auch so empfehlen.
Fast
eine geistesgegenwärtige Reaktion.
Aber überlebt man damit
2 Stunden im Eiswasser?
Waren es wirklich 2 Stunden?
Wir haben schon
über die Zeitangaben gesprochen.
Die sind kritisch zu bewerten.
Wir können es heute
nicht mehr nachvollziehen.
Diese Zeitangabe kam von ihm,
einer Person,
die um ihr Leben gekämpft hat,
traumatisiert war.
Das ist nicht die allerbeste Quelle.
Es gibt einige Faktoren,
die sein Überleben begünstigt haben.
Er ist wahrscheinlich einer,
der als Letztes
vom Schiff gegangen ist.
Er hat sich im Wasser
nicht so viel bewegt.
Und er hatte das Glück,
ein Faltboot zu finden.
Wenn all das zusammenkommt,
steigt die Chance, zu überleben.
Aber vom Faltboot
wurde er nicht aufgenommen?
Das stimmt.
Das Faltboot
wurde nicht als Boot benutzt,
sondern als Floß.
Das war also
eine wackelige Angelegenheit.
Aber auf dem Faltboot
waren einige seiner Kollegen.
Es gibt die These, dass er sich
so abstützen konnte am Faltboot,
dass sein Oberkörper
aus dem Wasser ragte.
Das würde
zu seinen Verletzungen passen.
Wir haben Daten dazu.
Seine Füße waren geschwollen.
Das könnte darauf hinweisen,
dass er nur mit den Beinen
im Wasser war.
Aber der Oberkörper nicht.
Okay.
Wenn Jack das also
genauso gemacht hätte wie Charles,
paddeln, kein wildes Schwimmen,
nicht rumprügeln,
hätte er es zum Boot schaffen können.
Das klingt
nach einer schönen Geschichte,
aber Jack
hatte noch ein anderes Problem.
Er hatte keine Rettungsweste.
Durch die Rettungsweste
musste Charles
nicht so viel Energie aufwenden,
um sich im Wasser
aufrecht zu halten.
Und die Rettungsweste ist auch
eine schützende Isolierschicht.
Man ist im extrem kalten Wasser,
und sie schützt etwas vor der Kälte.
All das hatte Jack nicht.
D.h., sein Überleben
in dieser Situation
wäre wieder
unwahrscheinlich gewesen.
Das sagte auch James Cameron
in seinem Experiment.
Er räumt Jack dort
nur gute Überlebenschancen ein,
wenn Rose ihre Rettungsweste abgibt.
Die hätte er niemals angenommen.
Deswegen sage ich:
Jack, wenn du auf dem Schiff bist,
geistesgegenwärtiger agieren
und eine Rettungsweste schnappen
und mitnehmen.
Es gab genug Rettungswesten
auf dem Schiff.
Generell ist die Schiffssituation
die beste.
Ein Großteil der Überlebenden
hat es von dort
auf eins der Rettungsboote geschafft.
Lasst uns ein Stück zurückgehen
und schauen,
welche Chancen
Jack da gehabt hätte.
Lisa, erklär uns
die Situation aus dem Film.
Frauen und Kinder zuerst.
Nach dieser Devise
werden die Rettungsboote gefüllt.
Doch viele Glauben nicht
an den Untergang
und wollen nicht ihre Männer
und Söhne zurücklassen.
Auch Rose steigt nur unter Zureden
ihres Noch-Verlobten
und ihres Geliebten Jack
in ein Boot.
Sie springt kurzerhand wieder raus,
um bei Jack zu sein.
You're so stupid.
Das gefällt ihrem Verlobten
gar nicht.
Er jagt sie mit einer Waffe
über das Schiff.
So, dass Jack und Rose
in die Gänge flüchten müssen,
die mit Wasser gefüllt sind.
Mit Mühe
schaffen sie es wieder an Deck,
wo man um die letzten Boote kämpft.
Im Film darf Jack nicht mit.
Aber hätte er, historisch gesehen,
überhaupt in eins der Boote gekonnt?
Er ist nicht nur ein Mann,
sondern auch Passagier 3. Klasse.
Im Film wurde
ein wichtiger Faktenfehler gemacht:
die verschlossenen Gittertüren.
Die 3. Klasse hatte die ganze Zeit
freien Zugang zum Deck.
Die Gittertüren
waren nicht verschlossen.
Aber sie hatten einen Nachteil,
weil das Boot so konstruiert war,
dass der Weg zu den Rettungsbooten
von der 3. Klasse sehr lang war.
Die waren auf dem Deck
der 1. Klasse.
Noch ein anderer Punkt kommt hinzu:
Die Crew und die Passagiere haben
die Situation nicht ernst genommen.
Will you hold the boat?
I have to run back to my room.
Sit down!
Viele Menschen haben sich nicht
auf den Weg gemacht.
Passagiere der 3. Klasse
mussten erst mal ihre Sachen packen.
Da ging sehr viel zeit verloren.
Aber für Jack war die Tatsache,
dass er ein Mann war,
das größte Risiko,
nicht zu überleben.
Sie hätten es Jack
in dieser Auf-Leben-und-Tod-Situation
verweigert?
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Das Credo "Frauen und Kinder zuerst"
war total üblich
und wurde auch bei anderen
Schiffsunglücken so umgesetzt.
Auf der Backbord-Seite
war man strickt.
Man hat nur Frauen und Kinder
auf die Boote gelassen,
auch wenn Plätze frei waren.
Auf der Steuerbord-Seite
hat man die Boote
teilweise mit Männern aufgefüllt.
Das kann man sehen
an den historischen Daten,
dass auch Männer
in den Booten waren.
Allerdings wurden auch da
die Plätze knapp.
This strutting martinet
isn't letting any men on at all.
There's one on the other side
letting men on.
Well then, that's our play.
Es ist also eine Zeitfrage.
Und sie verplempern viel Zeit.
Die Verfolgungsjagd
mit dem Verlobten von Rose.
Das ganze Entkommen.
In einer Szene
sind sie auf dem oberen Deck.
Da ist eine Uhr im Raum.
Die zeigt 02:10 Uhr.
Was bedeutet das für Jack?
02:10 sind 10 Minuten
vor dem Untergang.
5 Minuten vor dem Untergang
wurde wahrscheinlich
das letzte Rettungsboot abgelassen.
An Bord waren 40 Frauen und Kinder
und nur 2 Männer.
Für dich mal so eine Dimension.
Jack hätte großes Glück haben müssen
und er hätte schnell sein müssen,
um auf dieses Boot zu kommen.
Okay, das wird mega knapp.
Wir können an dieser Stelle
zusammenfassen.
Das mit der Wandverkleidung
wird nichts,
weil Jack mit Rose zusammen
drauf muss.
Das kostet zu viel Energie.
Die hat er nicht,
weil er sich geprügelt hat.
Das mit dem Faltboot wird nichts,
weil er sich keine Rettungsweste
eingepackt hat.
Er würde zu schnell
im Wasser auskühlen.
Und die Sache mit den Rettungsbooten
klappt nicht,
weil er durch die Flucht
vor Rose' Verlobten in Zeitnot kommt.
Wenn wir das mal runterbrechen,
ist eigentlich
seine Liebe zu Rose das Problem.
What?
Eigentlich für Rose auch, weil
sie bleibt wegen ihn auf dem Schiff.
Sie hatten eigentlich
noch ein anderes Problem:
Sie hatten schon auf dem Schiff
Kontakt zu dem kalten Meerwasser.
Das wäre ein Problem
für beide geworden?
Auf jeden Fall.
Es gibt ein historisches Beispiel
von Menschen,
die zu viel Wasserkontakt hatten
und gestorben sind.
Es gab 2 Faltboote.
Die konnten nicht abgelassen werden.
Sie wurden vorher
vom Meerwasser weggespült.
Auf eins dieser Faltboote
konnte sich unser Charles retten.
In das 2. Faltboot konnten sich
einige Menschen reinretten,
aber da war Wasser drin.
Diese Menschen hatten die ganze Zeit
Kontakt zum Meerwasser.
Von denen
hat nur die Hälfte überlebt.
Okay, krass.
Jack und Rose sind an Bord
permanent im Wasser,
komplett, mit dem ganzen Körper.
Wir haben nicht einbezogen,
dass sie schwimmen, das Kind retten.
Das ist hier ein harter Schlag
für die ganze Story.
Beide hätten es wahrscheinlich
schon auf dem Schiff nicht überlebt.
Die Fan-Diskussion, wer es
auf die Wandverkleidung schafft,
ist sinnlos.
It's absurd.
Mmh, ist gut, oder?
- Hm.
Schön, dass du da warst.
- Danke, hat Spaß gemacht.
Ein Dank geht raus
an Lisa von Giga TV Mag,
die uns die filmischen Sachen
eingeordnet hat.
Und danke an die Schauburg in Dresden
für das geile Popcorn
und den Kinosaal.
Sagt ihr doch mal:
Wie hat euch die Folge gefallen?
Lasst dazu einen Kommentar da.
Ihr könnt schreiben,
wer euer Lieblings-Jack ist.
Vergesst nicht, diesen Kanal zu:
- Abonnieren.
Und:
- Die Glocke zu drücken.
Wir können uns bald wiedersehen.
Welchen Film wollen wir checken?
- Pearl Harbor?
Klingt gut, machen wir.
Tschüss.
- Ciao.
*Melodie: "My heart will go on"*
♪ Hier, da ... sind Videos am Start.
♪ Findet Nemo im Check.
♪ Oder Giga TV Mag.
Copyright MDR 2023